Peter Gammons joins us here on the Rich
Eisen show how are you Peter I'm doing
great rich I just I just got back last
night from Cooperstown and Baseball Hall
of Fame and that is always my favorite
weekend of the entire year and what you
were talking about the guy is realizing
it more the day after the induction
ceremonies I always do a forum for the
hall with the inductees and it's
actually the best time because they're
they're really relaxed it's all over you
know that it's the next morning and they
have so much fun talking into swapping
stories but it was really interesting
what really struck them was after the
ceremony when they hang were they going
and they hang the plaques up on the wall
they all one by one they all go to see
their plaques up on the wall and that's
the moment for all of a sudden they
realize Tim Raines had said to me too I
mean I just woke up today this is the
first day of my life well I've woken up
and said how the whole thing and he said
that just it's such an incredible dream
and players are so humbled and I
remember years ago Tom Seaver who was
always has been revered of a Baseball
Hall of Fame said to me you know the way
will process and the way people feel
about is that we are members of the most
exclusive club in America
that's what baseball players eyes but
still he said you can't buy your way in
you can't be born into it it's all about
merit achievement and I think that
that's what really hits athletes where
they get to go to their Sports Hall
famous you know this is not political
it's not about money it's not you know
it's all entirely about what I did in
terms of merit and achievement man who
received the Jay G Taylor [ __ ] Award
for outstanding baseball writing Peter
Gammons here on the Rich Eisen show so
let's talk about and well put about
Cooperstown I just love my a couple of
ceremonies I was able to cover for ESPN
out there and Cooper's
New York that was incredible and
everybody should go stop by the Baseball
Hall of Fame and Museum up there so
let's let's talk about what didn't go
down yesterday
Peter why why didn't sack Britain get
moved yesterday they just didn't get
very much offered I mean I was told I
think what didn't happen the most
important thing was a Houston to do
anything I mean the Baylor now that's
fine but I mean we don't know if he
could pitch three out of four days out
of the bullpen and pitch without warming
up twenty minutes probably not so but
used to them Houston made no effort
really they they have a line of seven or
eight young players in their
organization um two of whom I think
would be considered prime guys and they
just little trait and they're offered
the Orioles the Orioles who felt they
were insulted by it and I know the Mets
felt the same way about elder when they
came to it to them about about a
reliever I mean I think it was funny I
mean perfect is great and I understand
for us Whitley and I understand the
young outfielder but I don't understand
if a guys are seventh or eighth best
prospect and you have a chance for you
may not have another chance to win like
this and I think sometimes you have to
take that gamble I know they're worried
they're very worried that Jose Altuve
will not be a long-term astro the East
I'll gots got worst as an agent he's
probably they think that there's still
Ohio prologue business from George
Springer from when he first came up and
they tried it some of the minor leagues
if you wouldn't would design a long-term
contract and there were a lot of hard
feelings that they're afraid they'll
lose two of their best players in the
next three years so they they want to
hold on to all their prospects but you
know what happens when a couple of guys
get hurt I mean right now I'm already
worried about Lance McCullers I mean
Wednesday Skycam pitch hundred fifty
leagues in big leagues
I'm not sure it's ever going to happen
so I think they had to go out and get
somebody
and they didn't do it I think I'm sort
of like the conversation everyone in the
game had yes Wow
look you know what what what the Dodgers
did that was a great story look at the
ink he sees it getting sunny great that
was a big story and they were right but
if you turn around and you look at the
the Astros are the best record in the
American League but have some injury
questions and their pitching staff has
issues I think that was the most
stunning thing and well I think has
happened now as clearer than this
getting better and better as they go
along
and the Yankees clearly with the bullpen
deals they made with the White Sox and
then sparing Sonny gray and even once I
absolutely is going to be a huge pickup
for the website because he finally gives
them a really reliable hne guy to get
the Kimble which they have not had so I
look I say if those are going to 14th in
the American League playoffs that that
presumes of course websites be Kansas
City in the wild crowd but I'm just so
rolling here but but um where are the
[ __ ] going because they end up
winning a hundreds of five games in
getting knocked out in the first one in
the first round they play wow I hate to
see that happen but there are issues
electric except and it I mean it isn't
me it is a fascinating point that you
make there Peter about about the Astros
and how you know and how a team that
could just be on a roll suddenly doesn't
look as aggressive as they need to be in
a moment like this and we will see how
it plays out in August and I'm just keen
to see that you know know the JD
Martinez move for Arizona and Lucroy for
the Rockies I think are being overlooked
just because we assume that they're
these teams are just going to be cannon
fodder for the Dodgers
in a divisional series you know I'm
wondering what you make of the car the
the Diamondbacks and the Rockies chances
here with the Dodgers sitting right in
front of them
I worry a little bit about the youth in
the Colorado pitching staff but they
have great stuff and they really have in
terms of the positional players to play
every day I think they're the best team
nationally and so I mean they're very
dangerous and I I mean you go up against
Arizona you Clayton Kershaw is healthy
this game Zack Greinke could be can beat
anybody and the way some of their if
Bobby rate can be healthy that was a
terrible bully check for the head but if
he's healthy and and they make you know
they're your cable by the time they get
to the playoffs
they'll have they shouldn't have oles
and ahmud back
and they should be a their team should
be whole which they haven't been for two
months so they're they're an intriguing
team I I love that the National League
playoff potential the Dodgers have you
really good they're so deep it's
particularly now they're deeper not
another deeper Peter I mean I'm
wondering what do you think about about
the way Dave Roberts is going to set up
pitching now that he has the ability to
make sure Kershaw pitches on full
complement of rest in a five-game series
I'd want to start Kershaw because you're
definitely going to get two starts out
of them and one in five but in a in a
seven-game series will there be a
temptation to start them in Game three
maybe put Darvish in wood out there
first put Kershaw on a road in a game
three and save them for a game seven is
that a what do you what do you think
they're thinking right now
it's he's healthy I think the diet will
be after Kershaw the number one guy for
show that people just don't hit it and
the experience I mean because you can
get five innings then go to that bullpen
and by the way I love sin brownie I mean
I think they vote for now is so much
deeper
plus you know it's so walkable will be
in there for any in almost every night I
think come the playoffs and they're
really good and I did have benches so
deep
I mean people talk about well they're
vulnerable what candid fishing will lead
the major leagues and home loans and
o-p-s against left-handed today I guess
if Chris Taylor and ovals Gogh is a I've
kind of changed that team they're really
interesting them but yeah if you end up
playing Washington for instance you just
still know if Strasberg's back
I mean Scherzer Strasburg if he's total
last night with Jill get solace from any
given night he can be almost unhittable
so I mean there's a lot and I think the
Cubs by that time will be will be very
very good i I think that has a chance to
be a really great group of four or five
teams so I really believe that in there
um now I mean to be talking about the
postseason to earlier I became if you
start thinking about how it lines up yep
I mean that's why I wondered sometime
this month he may have already got on
but Justin Verlander is going to go on
waivers now I just kind of need to get
really have money but they can't ask the
prospects now they kick to eat they pay
the rest of the contract or if you can
get Justin Verlander at thirty million
dollars a year for three years and not
give up a prospect I mean if you're a
good team I left beat it the Cubs which
I don't think they would but if you're
the Nationals if you're Houston you're
the awfully tempted to do that I think
it's a fascinating scenario as far as
because that there had been no waiver
deals after the trading deadline I mean
David Cone one of the little service of
Blue Jays in 92 he was at an August 30
waiver deal Don Sutton in 1982 not to go
too far back in history but I mean the
the Brewers
paducah Mitchell won the same award got
hurt in September was out for the rest
of the year they got Don Sutton on
waivers and went to the seventh game of
the World Series so we still may see
something that's that gets all the loose
elastic here lat
said Peter last one for you barring
something shocking like that happening
in August with Verlander maybe being
picked up on waivers by somebody in the
hunt now that we are through the trade
deadline who do you think makes the
World Series in 2017 I think it will be
the Dodgers I do think they'll make it
because I do believe the Kershaw will
come back and the layoff may have
actually helped just because he's pitch
so many is he so intense I think
sometimes he would never admit it by the
king is from Warren down a little bit by
the time he gets select over I want to
see him healthy and soft and I'll stick
to my preseason prediction and I still
stick to the Cleveland Indians being in
the World Series although I'm going to
be really fascinated to watch the
Yankees because I think 1 to 11 they may
have it may end up with pretty close to
the best fishing the American Lakes is
amazing it is amazing Peter thanks for
the time
really appreciate it rich thanks so much
always love it that's Peter Gammons the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that video be sure
to download our app and I'll be sure to
move week six games to Saturday for that
wedding you have to go to